DANA PERINO, "THE FIVE"
DANA PERINO, "THE FIVE."
>> OH, MY.
ADAM SCHIFF ADMITS HE MUST --
MUST HAVE BEEN CLEAR ABOUT HE
UNLEASHED THE IMPEACHMENT
CIRCUS.
WHEN A POLITICIAN SAYS THEY
SHOULD BE CLEAR, THEY MEAN I
WISH YOU HAD NOT CAUGHT ME LYING
TO YOUR FACE.
>> AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH
MORE CLEAR AND IT WAS BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION I WAS REFERRING TO
THE FACT, FILING A COMPLAINT AND
WE HAD NOT HEARD FROM THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND AT THAT TIME,
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH MORE
CLEAR.
>> Greg: INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
BE CLEAR, JUST BE HONEST, BIT
OTHERWISE IT'S LIKE HUNTER
BITING SANG ALTHOUGH HE DID
NOTHING WRONG, HE'S NOT GOING TO
DO IT ANYMORE.
HUNTER SAYS HE WILL WORK FOR
CHINA BECAUSE WE FOUND OUT HE
WAS WORKING FOR CHINA.
SO SHOULD THE TRANSPARENCY ALL
THE WHILE SAYING THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER MIGHT NOT
TESTIFY.
BECAUSE IT IS A SAFETY CONCERN
HE MAINTAINS.
WE ALL KNOW CIA AGENTS CAN'T
PROTECT THEMSELVES AGAINST
NONEXISTENT THREATS OVER THE
GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT HIM FROM
YOUR AUNT SALLY.
>> OR PRIMARY INTEREST IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT PERSON IS
PROTECTED.
INDEED NOW THERE IS MORE THAN
ONE WHISTLE-BLOWER PROTECTED.
GIVEN THAT WE ALREADY HAVE THE
RECORD, WE DON'T NEED THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WASN'T ON THE
CALL TO TAKE PLACE WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE CALL.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE CAN COME
WITH THE DETAILS ABOUT THE
CONDITIONALITY OF MILITARY AID
OR MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT
THAT MAY NOT BE NECESSARY TO
TAKE STEPS THAT MIGHT REVEAL THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S IDENTITY TO DO
THAT.
>> Greg: NOT NECESSARILY SO
MUCH FOR TRANSPARENCY BUT LIKE
EVERYTHING THE DEMS HAVE NOT
THOUGHT THIS THROUGH.
NOT ONLY WILL YOU IMPEACH TROMP,
YOU WILL DO IT IN SECRET IN THE
DARK REVERSING AN ELECTION, AN
ANONYMOUS GUY THAT YOU WILL
NEVER, EVER SEE BESIDES THE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS WHAT THE DEMS STANDS FOR
AND IT MIGHT NOT SIT WELL BUT
ANOTHER WHITE -- WIDE-EYED LIVE.
HOW ABSURD THE STORY LOOKS.
BETTER TO HIDE IT FROM YOU.
SO THE DEMS MUST RELY ON A
SIMPLY RETORT.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT, YOU
WANT TO IMPEACH HIM TO FIND OUT
IT IS GARBAGE.
THEY KNOW IT, WE KNOW IT, THE
GOOD NEWS, YOU KNOW IT TOO.
SO YOU KNOW, JOINING US, AN
AMAZING IMPRESSION OF
ADAM SCHIFF READING NURSERY
RHYMES.
LET'S DO IT, OKAY?
>> AND NOW, ADAM SCHIFF READS
NURSERY RHYMES.
>> HUMPTY DUMPTY SAT ON A WALL.
MR. DEMPSEY, THE WALLS
REPRESENTS OUR CORRUPT
PRESIDENT.
HUMPTY DUMPTY HAD A GREAT FALL.
CLEARLY, A REFERENCE TO THE FALL
OF OUR DEMOCRACY UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Greg: THAT CREEPS THE HILL
OUT OF ME.
ALMOST AS MUCH AS THE REAL
ADAM SCHIFF, JUDGE.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE LOOKS
LIKE ADAM SCHIFF, BUT THE TRUTH
IS, WHY ARE THEY SO WORRIED
ABOUT THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER?
AND DIDN'T OBAMA FIRE AT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IN FAST AND
FURIOUS?
I'M TELLING YOU, HE DID.
THAT WAS HORRIBLE, OKAY?
>> Greg: I'M NOT USED TO
HAVING YOU HERE.
>> Judge Jeanine: SCHIFF LIGHT
IN SO IF YOU MISSPOKE, YOU LIED.
YOU CREATED A NARRATIVE, YOU GOT
LAWYERS STARTING TWEETING, YOU
ARE A LIAR AND THAT IS THE END
OF IT.
>> Jesse: THE THING IS WE HAVE
PROTECTED WHO KILLED 19 PEOPLE
AND I THINK THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
WILL BE FAIRLY SECURE.
IT IS OBVIOUS THAT ADAM SCHIFF
WANTS TO PROTECT HIMSELF, BUT
THE SECRECY THAT HE CRAVES IS
SECRECY FOR HIMSELF.
AND HE SHOULD.
>> I DON'T WANT TO TELL YOU HOW
TO DO THE GG SHOW, BUT NEXT TIM
TIME, A VERY GOOD JOB.
AND ADAM SCHIFF LOOKS GOOD, NIC
NICE.
AND SO REALLY NICE LOOKING, HE
LOOKS LIKE HE'S TRYING TO
SILENCE THE WHISTLE-BLOWER,
ADAM SCHIFF.
WHAT IS THE POINT?
A SECRET AGENT AND THE
IMPEACHMENT BEHIND THE AMERICAN,
THAT IS WHAT'S GOING ON BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO SEE WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
THEY DON'T WANT REPUBLICANS TO
ASK, WHY WERE YOU IN CAHOOTS
WITH EACH OTHER YOU AND
ADAM SCHIFF PEOPLE?
WHY DID YOU WHY ON THE FLOOR
WITH NO CONTACT WITH CONGRESS.
AND THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER,"
DANA.
BREAKING NEWS ALERTS.
POINTS OUT VERY INTERESTING
THINGS ABOUT HOW ALL OF THIS
HAPPENED.
ADAM SCHIFF HIRED A WAY TO
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
OFFICIALS FROM THE TROMP
WHITE HOUSE RIGHT BEFORE THE GUY
BLEW THE WHISTLE.
SO HE STEALS A WAY TO
OBAMA/CLINTON PEOPLE FOR THE NSC
AND THE NEXT MONTH, ALL OF A
SUDDEN THE WHISTLE-BLOWER COMES
TO CONTACT THE COMMITTEE, THAT
HE HIRED THOSE GUYS FROM IN THE
WHISTLE WAS BLOWN.
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF QUESTIONS
HE DOESN'T WANT ANSWERED BY
REPUBLICANS.
>> Greg: DANA, PEOPLE SAY IT
IS A KOOK, BUT IT DOESN'T LOOK
GOOD DOING THIS BEHIND THE
SCENES IN THE MID-DARK
APPEARANCE BEFORE THE DEMOCRATS
STARTED TO HEAR THAT AND THEY
WERE ON RECESS LAST WEEK AND
THEY DID THEIR TOWN HALL
MEETING.
YOU SAW A FEW DEMOCRATS AND I
THINK ONLY LIKE SEVEN ARE NOT ON
BOARD FOR IMPEACHMENT BUT MORE
CAME BACK FROM THE TOWN HALL
SAYING "YOU KNOW, I THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE THE VOTE.
WE SHOULD MAKE SURE IT IS FAIR."
AND YOU SEE THEIR TOWN HAS
CHANGED A LITTLE BIT ON THAT.
>> Jesse: LET'S GO TO THE
TROMP WHEAT WITH HUNTER BIDEN
AND THE NEXT MOVE.
THIS ISN'T THE ONE I WANTED.
YOU ARE FIRED, WHOEVER THIS IS.
THIS WAS A TWEET ABOUT HUNTER --
>> Geraldo: I URGE THE
PRESIDENT TO NOT COOPERATE.
HE'S COOPERATING MUCH TOO MUCH
AS IT IS UNLESS AND UNTIL THERE
IS A HEARING OR BOTH RATHER ON
THE IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY, THERE
SHOULD BE NO COOPERATION BY THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THERE WAS A VOTE FOR NIXON IN
'70 FOR A VOTE FOR CLINTON IN
'98 AND THERE SHOULD BE A VOTE
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP RIGHT NOW
AND 19, THE FACT THEY ARE
PROCEEDING WITHOUT A VOTE IN
SECRET AND MAKE THIS A STAR
CHAMBER, AND THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD JUST --
>> Greg: THE TRANSCRIPT IS
FINE.
NO WITNESSES.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THERE IS
A TRICKLE OUT OF CERTAIN
WITNESSES, ON THURSDAY.
WHY?
WHY COOPERATE AT ALL?
IF THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN THEIR
OWN IMPEACHMENT ENOUGH TO HAVE A
VOTE ON THE INQUIRIES, THEN TO
HELL WITH HIM.
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
SO, BUT SHE IS DISCUSSING WITH
OTHER DEMOCRATS ABOUT
IMPRISONING WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS TO GO UP TO THE SECRET
HEARING THEY ARE HAVING.
>> Dana: THAT IS NOT HOW OLD
WILL MAKE ANY OF THIS WORKS.
BUT SHE SAID THAT IN A TOWN HALL
BECAUSE SHE GOT JAMMED UP.
>> Jesse: SHE WAS DRUNK?
>> Dana: THAT IS NOT WHAT THAT
MEANS.
>> Greg: DRINKING A LOT OF
GIN.
DANA, THAT IS QUITE A SMEAR.
[LAUGHTER]
WOW!
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK IT'S
TRUE.
>> Greg: CAN I -- DO WE HAVE A
TWEET ON HUNTER BIDEN?
ANYWAY, TROMP SAID WOW, HUNTER
BIDEN FORCED TO LEAVE A CHINESE
COMPANY.
AND WHAT THEM WRAP THEIR GREASY,
PROTECTIVE ARMS AROUND HIM.
ONLY SOFTBALL QUESTIONS FOR HIM,
PLEASE.
OKAY.
IS HUNTER BEING TREATED FAIRLY
OR UNFAIRLY?
>> Judge Jeanine: HUNTER IS
BEING TREATED, PEOPLE WORRY
ABOUT A DOUBLE STANDARD AT THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IF I WERE TO TRY THIS CASE
AGAINST HUNTER BIDEN, THE FIRST
THING I WOULD BE IS TO PUT UP A
STATEMENT OF HIS FATHER AND DO A
TIMELINE OF WHEN HIS FATHER WAS
AND POINTED FOR UKRAINE IN
CHINA.
THIS GUY HAS GOT ALL KINDS OF
PROBLEMS WITH HIS OWN PERSONAL
DEMONS.
I UNDERSTAND WE ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO TALK ABOUT THOSE.
>> Jesse: REALLY?
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THEM?
>> Jesse: ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT ADDICTIONS?
>> Judge Jeanine: HE GOT
THROWN AROUND THE NAVY, COCAINE.
NOW THE GUY IS GETTING
$12.5 BILLION FROM THE CHINESE.
THEY DON'T GIVE YOU ANYTHING.
IT WAS BECAUSE HE USED HIS
FATHER'S POSITION.
>> Dana: THEM COMING OUT AND
SAYING HE WILL NO LONGER DO IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: DOES THAT
MEAN HE SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT
WHILE VICE PRESIDENT?
>> Dana: NOT ONLY THAT BUT
JOE BIDEN LAST WEEK SAID HE
WOULD HAVE A POLICY IF HE
BECOMES PRESIDENT, HE WOULD HAVE
NOBODY IN HIS FAMILY WORK IN THE
RIGHT HOUSE.
IS THAT TRUE FOR HIS
VICE PRESIDENT?
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE THE ACTUAL
PARALLEL.
THE OTHER THING FOR TOMORROW
NIGHT WHEN THE DEBATE HAPPENS
BASICALLY BUY IT AND SAID DON'T
DO IT, DON'T -- BUT BIOTIN HAS
AN INTERVIEW TOMORROW.
THAT WILL BE THE FIRST QUESTION
AND HE WILL PROBABLY GET
APPLAUSE FOR HIS RESPONSE, AND
THEN HER LIPS AND THE OTHER 2020
DEMOCRATS COME AFTER HIM, THAT
WILL BE THE FIRST HEADLINE
AND THEN BIDEN TAKING ON TROMP
AND THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN ALL
ALONG.
>> Greg: THEY HAVE TO GET ON
THE SAME PAGE, I TALKED TO MY
FATHER.
SO, HE IS EITHER IGNORANT OR
CORRUPT AND I DON'T KNOW WHICH
ONES MORE DANGEROUS.